and here comes chris paul and the
phoenix suns
will give it to booker with a drive and
a season high of 47.
and give credit to this son's team
they have been absolutely locked in they
came out the first half
punched them in the face and have
competed all game
have withstood this run by the lakers
and it looks like a technical
technical foul call on booker morrison i
think it's
morris and
i was gonna say it was crowded
well let's see what they do here
booker is gone and crowder is gone
and crowder was on the bench so a little
trash talking going on
not exactly sure what happened
it looked like crowder knew right away
that he was ejected
and gladly ran to the bench but you got
to tip your hat to devin booker
i mean just the performance that he's
had throughout this entire series
not quite sensational in games three and
four but
all the other games including this one
47 point performance
putting this team on his back and monty
williams willie green the coaching staff
imploring him to keep his cool
so he's been ejected and for the phoenix
suns
who have not been to the playoffs for 11
years
in a first round series with the
defending champions they have won
iconic lebron james
and this has not happened very often
that you see a defending champion in the
first round lose
on their home court
and they're going to stop play chris
paul
who is very instrumental in this fourth
quarter
leadership